bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que la française des jeux
doit s'inquiéter cette enquête
européenne est bien le problème c'est
qu'à partir du moment où on veut confier
les paris sportifs
la française des jeux et bien il faut il
fallait éviter de la privatiser on a ça
a été une bêtise énorme l'état s'est
privé de ressources massives et d'une
entreprise extrêmement rentable
plusieurs milliers d'euros par an à
partir du moment où on privatise la
française des jeux on peut difficilement
lui donner l'exclusivité des paris
sportifs donc je ne suis pas juriste
donc je ne connais pas les clauses
précises de l'accord qui a été passée
mais à partir du moment où on a à faire
une entreprise privée il est totalement
logique que les autres entreprises
privées
deux mondes pouvoir accéder à ce marché
donc effectivement là on a ce que ce
qu'on appelle dans le jambon de ces lois
ou allemandes et écolo mission
distorsion de concurrence
donc il est normal que les concurrents
de la française des jeux se plaignent de
cette situation et il est tout à fait
légitime de leur part d'avoir introduit
une plainte à bruxelles
et pourtant le ministère des finances
s'est dit totalement confiant dans la
manière dont cette opération a été menée
votre regard sur ce point écoutez
peut-être que juridiquement s'effondrer
mais en tout cas à partir du moment où
on privatise la française des jeux
bah on se met
on se plie aux règles qui sont celles de
la concurrence entre entreprises privées
et donc donc une fois de plus je ne
connais pas les clauses de l'accord mais
passé un accord c'est vouloir se
soustraire aux règles de la concurrence
donc on ne peut pas dire d'un côté qu'on
privatise une entreprise et l'autre côté
dire qu'un ballon elle va être
elle va échapper aux règles de la
concurrence et à la fameuse concurrence
libre et non faussée des traités
européens
donc il ya un problème de cohérence ici
de la part de notre gouvernement et ils
peuvent se dire confiant peut-être que
juridiquement s'est fondée mais enfin ça
paraît assez acrobatique
à partir du moment où on privatise à
partir du moment où on décide de
soumettre cette entreprise aux règles de
la concurrence privée
il faut pas s'étonner que d'autres
entreprises demandent à ce qu'on fasse
jouer la concurrence
alors en échange la priverait de la
privatisation de la fdj à 380 millions
d'euros sur 25 ans versée par
l'entreprise à l'état est ce que est ce
que ça vous semble suffisant avec le
recul quand on voit les revenus nets
annuels de la française des jeux
non évidemment votre question contient
la réponse non évidemment c'est très peu
par rapport à la formidable manne qui
est la française des jeux
cette étude entreprise publique avec de
bonnes raisons d'ailleurs qu'elles
soient publiques indépendamment des
rôles donc à leur apporter un je vous
rappelle quand même qu'un jeu peut être
addictif qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
malades de cela et donc comme l'alcool
comme d'autres drogues
la française des jeux avait été
nationalisée à cette fin c'était une
formidable manne pour l'état et il a
renoncé à cette manne contre eux un
petit pourboire ça me paraît très très
peu par rapport
longtemps j'ai pas exactement les
montants en tête mais on est de l'ordre
de plusieurs millions d'euros par an de
revenus auxquels ont renoncé donc là
c'est un petit pourboire pour faire
passer la pilule
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur rtl
france dany longue économiste membre des
économistes atterrés
merci à vous